It is time for Drew's News.
Your good news machete
for cutting your way through the thick forest news.
(audience laughs)
(Drew makes cutting sounds)
And with me at the desk
is my favorite co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
Hi, everybody! Hi!
(audience applauds)
Slasher.
(Ross and Drew make cutting sounds)
Well, it's Women's History Month,
and we're starting with a phenomenal woman
who is very near and dear to this show.
Gayle King.
PopSugar just published Gayle's thoughts
on why it's not so bad
to put yourself first.
She says that girls are raised
to take care of everyone else before themselves,
and it took her many years,
all the way up to her divorce,
to realize selfishness can be a positive,
not just a negative.
And it is vital to prioritize yourself.
And Gayle says, quote,
"When you're happy with yourself,
"when you're happy with the job you're doing,
"you're a better person, period.
"And this makes you a better employee,
"which means you're certainly a better mother,
"which means you're certainly a better friend."
The gospel, according to Gayle.
(audience applauds)
(Ross laughs)
Right?
I love it.
If Gayle King says it.
She's the best.
And to read the full essay,
go on PopSugar now.
I love this.
I did too, you know, when you think about,
whenever you talk to somebody,
who's maybe later in their life,
and you say, "What would you tell
"a younger version of yourself?"
It's always to take it easy on myself,
to be kinder to myself, to love myself sooner.
And I just, I can't agree with Gayle more.
The sooner you can do a little self care,
and just nurture yourself,
the better person you'll be.
Ugh, I just struggle
(audience applauds)
with the oxygen mask.
Oh, that analogy.
That analogy never does it for me.
I'm like, we're not always like,
in a plain crash scenario.
I need like, a daily metaphor.
That isn't so severe and intense
like the oxygen mask.
And then self care is a term
that just feels too passive.
It doesn't have that fight in it.
I'm terrible at those things.
But I like how she's not talking about
necessarily pampering yourself.
It's just prioritizing yourself.
Well yeah,
(audience applauds)
and I think you have to love yourself,
and that's how you prioritize yourself.
Synonymous with self-care
can also be self-awareness.
And not the ego kind.
But the knowing what you need
to take care of others.
'Cause I love taking care of others.
I'm really good at it.
You are.
Not as great prioritizing myself.
So read the full article on PopSugar
and see what Gayle has to say.
And thanks, Gayle.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, we love you.
All right.
We also love, it is Design Week around here!
So let's talk about where pop culture,
something we love.
Oh, I love it.
Meets home decor, something else we love.
We've already talked on the show here
about how "Bridgerton" is inspiring interior design.
Oh, we love "Bridgerton!"
Oh my God, season two is coming out soon!
Like, any second.
I know!
I can't wait!
It's crowning!
(audience and Ross laugh)
Oh, I'm so proud of you!
Is that a double pun?
Yeah, that is a double pun! Wow, Drew!
Well, okay.
There are other shows that are inspiring
design out there.
Apartment Therapy reports,
an analysis of search data from the last year
found one big show people are inspired by
is the show "Sherlock."
People are loving that Victorian furnishing,
that, they call it clutter core design,
which is more is more kind of approach.
Cramming your space with vintage accessories
and trinkets.
That causes anxiety for me.
Too much, too much, too much.
(audience laughs)
It's true, you love a white box, Rossy.
I do, I loved the interior design of "Mad Men."
They say that one was a big influence as well.
Oh, very mid-century.
Yeah.
And now people are turning to "Friends"
for that 90's design aesthetic.
And I started thinking like,
what am I into now?
What's inspiring my design that I'm watching?
And I watch, just the worst.
I'm, you know...
You watch "90 Day Fiance."
"90 Day Fiance."
(audience laughs)
I was thinking of like,
what is my designer sense inspired by?
Those little pods in "Love is Blind."
(audience laughs)
I kind of want my own pod now.
Fun fact.
What?
The kitchen here, the way I designed it with Tom and Mel,
our production designers,
I was inspired by "The Handmaid's Tale" kitchen.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh!
All the shaker style that that show had,
if you think of "The Handmaid's Tale" kitchen,
and you look at our kitchen,
it might be like, "Oh, right."
(upbeat music)